I can't tell you what's gonna happen we
have a sleepy guy in a basement of a
house that the press is giving a free
pass to who doesn't want to do debates
because of kovat and lots of things are
happening right and I watched a couple
of interviews and I say oh I look
forward to this but they're keeping him
sheltered because of the coronavirus and
he's not moving around is that woven too
much former Vice President Biden
obviously is shelters in Delaware doing
a number of interviews a lot of local TV
actually if you look at our latest polls
in states Fox News polls they have Joe
Biden leading Donald Trump in Florida
Michigan and Pennsylvania we will bring
back to panel Jason let me start with
you the state of this race and you know
what the president's talking about there
versus Joe Biden's exposure he's kind of
climbing up in the polls even though
he's not out and about as much yeah I
think all things considered is probably
pretty satisfied with how things are
going he's obviously in this position
that no other candidate has been in
before where he's not only been pushed
aside because of the pandemic but he
can't even campaign like a normal
candidate what he's still raising a ton
of money he raised something like 46
million dollars last month and he's
still hanging in there or leading in a
lot of these swing states that are
expected to decide the election so all
things considered I think Joe Biden
probably thinks I'm doing all right
Carol I think that one of the more
telling numbers also net polling data
was that it seems that a majority a big
majority of the country doesn't always
believe the president when he's speaking
and Molly gave a little bit of a sense
of that we all have baby maybe as to why
and Biden
I've heard some Republican friends of
mine say well he's invisible and he's
weak and it's it's an eye W strategy I
said well he's also winning he is
winning so the odd W is working in his
favor I do think this won't last and
he'll have to end up laying out an
economic plan which I know that team of
this is working on and hopefully we'll
have a big brawl in in the summer in the
fall around how do we move the country
from this moment how do we spend in a
way the Jason's point that gets us to a
better place a stronger place in a more
vibrant place as a country and not just
been for spending sake yeah Molly the
former vice president said that he
thought and this was on a fundraising
call that the president was going to
push back the election somehow no
evidence of that didn't get called out
on it really about that he is behind the
eight ball when it comes to fundraising
versus the Trump campaign as we get
closer and closer to this head-to-head
moment yeah there's a lot of projection
going on I think in politics and it
reminds me a bit of in 2016 when there
were so many questions asked of
President now president Trump about
whether he would accept the election
results if he lost nobody thought to ask
Hillary Clinton or her supporters if
they would accept the election results
which turned out to be the much more
pressing question that we could have
gotten an answer to but the pandemic
really has it helped I think Biden at
first by consolidating support behind
him but now it's very difficult for him
to campaign and really get his message
out so it's a mixed bag for him all
right I have 30 seconds so I'll go Molly
Harold and Jason Joe Biden's vice
presidential pick you only get one I'm
not playing the casino just one pick
Molly first I think I'll go with Amy
Klobuchar I think she would be a strong
contender and make his make his
candidacy seem more serious Harold
you're gonna make some of my friends
upset with me Brett but uh but I'd have
to go with Gretchen Whitmer but as I sit
here tonight really Gretchen Whitmer
despite all of the push back in Michigan
you think she's still gonna come I think
they they he needs them win Michigan I
think she helps deliver there and look
Amy Klobuchar strong I think if he tries
to go Unni Larry Hogan would be
interesting but he missed he's missing a
he's not the right gender but i richard
whitmer but be my choice tonight all
right Jason I'm gonna go with Janet
Napolitano the former DHS secretary okay
panel thank you very much we finally got
two whole panels on a special report
thanks for being here